كما سمحت للرئيس السوداني السابق عمر
البشير بالدخول الى البلاد للمشاركه في
قمه الاتحاد الافريقي عام 2015 بينما كان
متهما انذاك بارتكاب اباده جماعيه وجرائم
حرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه لذلك اصدرت جنوب
افريقيا حصانه دبلوماسيه شامله لجميع
القاده الذين يتوقع ان يشاركوا في قمه
بريكس في اغسطس واعتبرت وزاره الخارجيه ان
منح الحصانات هدفه حمايه المؤتمر وضيوفه
في المقابل اعلن حزب التحالف الديمقراطي
المعارض في جنوب افريقيا يوم الثلاثاء عن
اتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه لاجبار الحكومه على
اعتقال بوتين في حال قرر حضور قمه دول
بريكس وضمان قيام الحكومه بتسليمه الى
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
بشكل عام تجده جنوب افريقيا نفسها في مازق
بين مواجهه روسيا حليفتها التاريخيه او
الحفاظ على العلاقات مع الغرب وعدم تنفيره
وايجاد توازن بهذا الشان اما في روسيا فقد
دعا المتحدث باسم الكراملان الى ان لا
تركز الدول الشريكه في بريكس على ما
اسماها القرارات غير القانونيه للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ضد الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين لم
تابعه البرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات